every single hashira has suddenly turned
into a demon how strong would they be
would they occupy the ranks of the 12
demon moons well let's find out
misuri lower moon three come closer
handsome
you look
delicious mitsuri is the only wielder of
the love breathing a breathing technique
that she made by altering flame
breathing which she learned from mangoku
if mitsuri was a demon she would
definitely be amongst the strongest and
occupy the ranks of the 12 kizuki so
it's safe to assume that in comparison
to the other hashiras she would occupy
the position of lower rank 3. mitsuri is
a young and very beautiful girl and this
would still be the case when she turns
into a demon her demonic appearance
would entail wearing more revealing and
sensual outfits she would use a similar
weapon as before but it would be much
longer and more of a whip than a sword
although her whip would be flexible it
would also be powerful enough to cut off
a human's head with one slash her
personality as a demon would be
completely different from her current
one she would have an immense craving
and desire for men with little to no
interest in dealing with or feeding on
women being a hashira turned demon she
would possess both blood demon arts and
her normal love breathing techniques in
her blood demon arts she may become
capable of hypnotizing and controlling
men kind of like zombies that she can
bend to her will and have them do
anything she commands this ability would
affect all male humans once they absorb
her blood since the lower moons are far
inferior compared to ashira's misuri
would inevitably be stronger than the
former lower moon 3 wakuraba
shinobu lower moon 2. are you gonna be
my next test subject oh
so exciting the insect pillar shinobu is
a hashira that wields the insect
breathing technique as a demon she would
occupy the position of lower moon too in
her demonic appearance she would closely
resemble an insect more specifically a
butterfly she would also grow a pair of
gigantic wings that she would use in
combat her nails would be laced with
poison these nails can infect and poison
humans when they are cut with them she
would become quite nerdy and inquisitive
always wanting to infect humans with her
poisons to determine its potency and to
keep making it stronger she would do
this both for fun to kill and devour and
for research purposes being a physically
weak person as a demon she would always
certainly rely on her poisons to kill
humans and eat them instead of gauging
it into hand-to-hand fights she would
retain her normal insect breathing
techniques as a demon with her blood
demon arts she would be capable of
releasing poison from her mouth into the
surrounding areas on an immensely large
scale she would be capable of
manipulating the properties of the
released poison by making it either
liquid solid or gaseous she would be
able to fight with these poisons however
she deems fit her poisons can be
solidified and made to take the shape of
a sword spear whip shield or whatever
weapons she so desires a cut from these
poison weapons would instantly make her
opponents become infected and die in
comparison to lower rank 2 which was
pitifully killed by muzon she would be
way stronger tengen lower rank one
bow before your god you mortals
tengen is the sound hashira and the only
shinobi amongst the ranks of the pillars
the lower rank one position would be his
for the taking should he become a demon
as lower rank one he would appear like a
typical shinobi dressed in a
shinobi-like attire and have three
beautiful female demons by his side at
all times a testament to his inherent
polygamous nature he would possess a
harsh personality towards humans but he
would be more sympathetic and kind
towards beautiful human females in this
state he would have an immense godlike
complex and an extremely flashy
lifestyle always wanting to be praised
and reverenced by all so it's safe to
say that he would be adorned with a lot
of jewelry his blood demon arts would of
course be sound based with this he would
be capable of releasing loud destructive
screams from his mouth that can flatten
a whole terrain and act as a repulsive
force to repel almost anything in its
path he would also be able to produce
sounds that can disorient humans and
make them go deaf or lose consciousness
would he be stronger than the previous
lower moon one enmu this question
doesn't even qualify as a debate as
tengen in his human form was easily able
to overpower daki an upper moon with
little to no effort
albania upper moon six you'll make a
perfect meal
for my snakes
go get him
obani is the serpent breathing user and
is one of the pillars in the demon
slayer series if he was to become a
demon he would look more serpent-like
possessing a long tongue think of early
versions of orochimaru from the naruto
series this time around he would have
two big snakes around his neck he could
use these snakes as weapons sending them
to attack demon slayers he would of
course possess a cunning personality his
blood demon art would allow him to
infect people with deadly snake venom
summon large destructive snakes to the
battlefield and strengthen his body with
snake-like properties wherein he can
move like a snake and crush people by
wrapping around them he would easily
overwhelm both daki and gyotaro if he
fights them individually but taking both
of them on at the same time may prove
difficult for him what do you think
would he be able to do it run goku upper
moon 5. become a demon and surpass your
human limits the flame hashira rangoku
would have two horns on his head with
the same facial appearance but with
bloodshot eyes he would still wear a
cape but this time one with pitch-black
colors having flame symbols engraved on
it his personality as a demon would see
him become unsympathetic and exhibit
disgust towards humans his blood demon
art would revolve around flames this
could let him summon and control flames
that can be capable of melting steel he
would also be able to release steam from
his body and cause severe burns on his
opponents rengoku in this form would
easily defeat the upper moon 5 yoko
moichiro upper moon 4. everything is so
clear to me now
being a demon is amazing a child prodigy
and a descendant of kokushibo moichiro
become a hashira at the age of 14 with
only two months of training being one of
the strongest teshira upper moon 4 is a
befitting position for him should he
ever become a demon he would always walk
around bare-chested in this form and his
hair would be short and pale white he
would stop being forgetful in fact he'll
become obsessed with reminiscing and
remembering all the events things and
experiences that he always forgot
devouring more human flesh would make
him unlock more of his memories as a
demon moichiro would possess the ability
to alter the weather and create
destructive lightning bolts that he can
use in battle his mist would possess
hallucigenic and aesthetic properties
that can easily make his opponents see
illusions and knock them unconscious
nakime wouldn't hold a candle to
moichiro in this form giyu upper moon 3.
don't worry
it will all be over soon you poor humans
as a hashira giyu is the third strongest
thus making the upper rank three up a
fitting position for him to occupy when
he becomes a demon as a demon he
wouldn't change his outfit or any aspect
of his appearance he would still appear
exactly the same as he was as a human
since he doesn't really care much about
anything and he sees little to no
importance in it his personality however
would revolve around him having extreme
sadness for the existence of humans his
goal would be to eliminate all humans
from the face of the earth because of
the unfair advantage demons possess
against them and because he sees them as
a weak species he would have a deep
sense of justification that he is doing
the right thing for the human race
giulio's blood demon art would be
extremely deadly against humans who lack
breathing techniques this demonic
ability would let him squeeze all forms
of fluid out of a human body thus
resuscitating and leaving them dead
instantly furthermore he would be
capable of bending controlling and
manipulating humans because the human
body is made up of 60 water this ability
is formed in line with his personality
and goals the eradication of humans but
not all humans are weak for instance
demon slayers hence his ability would
not affect humans who possess breathing
techniques because they are much
stronger and as such are not part of his
weaker species concept since his blood
demon art is mainly aimed towards humans
and doesn't really affect demons akasa
would probably prevail against giyu
sanemi upper moon 2. kill kill kill
every last one of you humans out of all
of the hashira turned to demons sundemi
would be the most wicked in his demonic
state he'd have a lot of scars engraved
all over his body taking the appearance
of scales his skin would be so hard and
tough that it can't be cut by ordinary
demon slayers tsunami would exhibit an
overwhelmingly evil personality he would
kill humans just for the fun of it even
if he doesn't want to eat them he'd be
more attracted to weaker and helpless
opponents and he'd enjoy toying with
them and keeping them alive as much as
possible showing his sadistic nature his
blood demon art would grant him the
ability to control wind on an
unprecedented scale he'd be capable of
causing wind-based natural disasters
such as hurricanes and tycoons he would
also gain combat based abilities being
able to propel the wind around him to
enable him to fly levitate and fight
mid-air he'd also be capable of forming
wind blades and throwing wind punches in
terms of defense he would be capable of
repelling attacks by using the
surrounding wind and erecting a
wind-based force field around himself
the current holder of the upper moon 2
title is doma and knowing how incredibly
strong he is it would be impossible to
predict the outcome of this fight it
would truly be a sight to behold yome
upper rank one you are really
unfortunate to stumble upon me now
prepare to meet your end demon slayer
yomi is currently the strongest demon
slayer and ashira in the entire demon
slayer core this seems kind of ironic
given the fact that he is blind in both
eyes he's a master of the stone
breathing technique not to mention that
he is the only hashira who doesn't wield
a sword but a mace instead what if gyome
was to become a demon being the
strongest filler he would obviously
occupy the spot of upper rank 1 in the
12 kazuki in terms of appearance he
would still retain his huge physique and
he'd have shining yellow eyes he would
no longer keep his hands in a
prayer-like state because this time
around he would lack remorse due to him
having a sense of pure evil from muzon
in terms of personality it would be safe
to say that he would still maintain his
normal persona as when he was a hashira
calm and collected being a hashira
turned demon he would possess both blood
demon art and his normal stone breathing
techniques his blood demon art may
revolve around earth-based manipulations
which would let him perform incredible
attacks some ideas would be changing the
terrain of his surroundings summoning
stone golems and being able to use the
earth to feel vibrations which would
allow him to easily sense and track his
opponents yeome in this state however
would still be inferior to kokushibo in
terms of strength this can be attributed
to the fact that kokoshibo is a hashira
turned demon and he possesses the second
strongest breathing technique ever moon
breathing as well as centuries of combat
experience click on this video where we
explained what the next hashira
generation would look like don't be shy
click it